hi so i strongly believe that in 2022
you can learn anything you want to as
long as you have stable internet and a
computer all the resources are online so
in this video i want to give you a few
resources if you're interested in
learning computational neuroscience so i
myself studied computational
neuroscience at the donors institute
during my master's degree and before
that i did my bachelor's in theoretical
physics so i think in general it doesn't
really matter what you did your
bachelor's or undergrad in as long as
it's a stem field subject but if you
want to go on to do a master or phd in
computational neuroscience there are
some skills that you need beforehand
that i will discuss in this video so i
went through everything that i learned
in my bachelor's and in my master's that
i now need in my phd in computational
neuroscience such that you may follow
this same path but way accelerated and
without some expensive university you
have to go to so in computational
neuroscience there are three skills you
really need to develop and that's
programming mathematics and neuroscience
of course so i will first delve a little
bit into programming so in general it's
assumed before you start your master's
even but also in your phd that you know
some programming so if in your
undergraduate you haven't learned any
type of programming it is good to kind
of start learning it and even if you
don't have an undergraduate it's good to
start learning programming as soon as
you can so in neuroscience the most
popular languages right now are python
and r and if you have to choose one of
them i would choose python probably to
begin with because from what i've heard
most people find python the most
intuitive at the beginning and in
general python has the biggest community
online so if you have any questions or
any doubts usually you can find some
people online that can answer your
questions for any type of programming
question but also some other languages
are still used and that's c plus plus
matlab and julia and c plus plus is
usually used for a little bit some older
code but some of my professors also
still only work in c plus so it's good
if you know a little bit and then matlab
is now slowly becoming out of trend but
especially in physics where i worked it
was really popular and julia is a new
language that is super fast it's i think
one of the fastest languages at the
moment so i think in the future it will
be a language that will be heavily used
but let's first start with python so if
you want to learn python i think one of
the best resources that i have ever used
is 100 days of code it's this course by
angela you and it's online i'll put it
here but it's amazing because from most
programming courses you don't start to
immediately program so they just teach
you the theoretical notions and all the
things aside of this but with 100 days
of code program you immediately start
programming and i think this is one of
the biggest things you need to learn
during programming is that you need to
start from the beginning building your
own games your own data analysis
programs your own projects and in this
course angela u really takes you from
the beginning
very beginning programming to pretty
advanced topics actually so even i i did
it i think two years ago i learned some
new skills that i didn't have before
then in general i would also if you're
gonna use python or r i would set up
jupiter notebooks so jupyter notebooks
are these kind of notebooks that look
like this and i think for programmers
this is not super commonly used i'm not
too sure but in science this is a really
nice way to write your code because in
between you can put your little queries
or your questions or theoretical notions
that you have
so if you write your code like this it's
almost written like a paper which then
in the end you can publish so i would
also learn how to use jupyter notebook
then the next skill you need to learn in
programming is machine learning and
machine learning in general is just a
really broad topic of all different kind
of algorithms you can use with big data
but also small data sets and the book
that i really like and still have
actually let me show you is this one so
it's pattern recognition and machine
learning by christopher bishop and i
actually sold all my books from my
masters and also my bachelor's but this
one i kept because it's just super good
and even now i still use it sometimes
ever as a reference but i think it is
maybe a little bit hard for beginners to
understand so there's also this course i
heard which is pretty good so it's a
course around machine learning it's just
called machine learning by andrew and
i'll put it up here and i think in
general i heard it's pretty nice but i
did my machine learning courses at
university so i'm not too sure and
another book that's quite commonly used
is information theory inference and
learning algorithms by david mckay and
i've read some of the chapters from his
book but because i have the bishop book
i didn't really feel the need to read it
fully but it is quite good as well i
think these two are pretty comparable so
just choose one of them basically and
then for the final few little skills i
would also learn some unix code if
you're added
so this is just how to use the terminal
because with computational neuroscience
you're using a lot of really big data
sets so to move them from one folder to
another for example or to compile a few
data sets into one big file this is most
easily done with the terminal and it's
just kind of nice if you know some of
the basic commands that you have to use
and then also i would start from the
beginning i wish someone told me this
when i started doing my bachelor but to
use github so github is just this place
where you put all your code and it's in
general used for version control but i
also really like it as kind of a library
of all the code i've ever written so i
didn't start using it until after my
master and i really regret this because
i made some pretty cool projects during
my master but now i use github and it's
just really nice to see some of the code
that i've written last year so yeah then
the next big skill you need is
mathematics and mathematics kindness
this broader term for also data science
statistics and even a little bit of
physics i think it's nice if you can
learn that mathematics is kind of a big
bottleneck for a lot of students that
i've seen so one of the skills you first
need to develop is just linear algebra
from what i've heard the introduction to
linear algebra by gilbert strang is
pretty good and he also has some courses
online so some of my friends that
haven't studied linear algebra are now
using his courses and they say it's
pretty nice and also i would just in
general use youtube so i really like
this channel three blue one brown and
it's just a really cute channel that
explains all the different type of
linear algebra things there are but also
other types of mathematics and even
though it seems really simple how they
explain it the topics they explain are
actually pretty complex in their course
so they did a really good job of
explaining super difficult topics in an
easy manner then the next skill you need
is data science and statistics and i
think for a lot of people this is the
most boring skill but it's actually
during your phd one of the skills you
will most heavily rely on because even
though you're studying neuroscience what
you have in the end are just big data
sets and to make any type of conclusions
or any type of statement you need
statistics to kind of make the
foundation for that statement so there
are a few courses that i liked so
fundamentals of statistics is one
probability the science of uncertainty
and data is another and i also really
like this book naked statistics which is
kind of more an intuitive way of
explaining some of the more difficult
topics in statistics and i think reading
that first and then taking a good course
on statistics is really nice way to go
and also if you haven't learned r at
this point yet this is a good point to
start applying the r language a little
bit because all the tutorials in our are
written specifically for using
statistics so i think it's one of the
best languages to learn statistics with
and lastly within mathematics i think
it's also nice to get a little bit an
overview of some of the concepts used in
physics because a lot of people that are
now doing computational neuroscience are
trained physicists so they will use some
of the models that are also used in
physics and one of the biggest areas
that you kind of need to know is
electromagnetism and this is because the
brain in general is an electrical
machine right so for example single cell
recordings the models that we use for
those are very similar to the models
that are used in physics i don't really
have a specific book that i super like
but the introduction to electromagnetism
is the one we used and is the one that's
most used in undergraduate courses but i
assume that there are probably better
resources out there because this is a
pretty dense book but you can start
there if you want to and then another
topic from physics that i would
personally dive into a little bit is
quantum physics and that's because
quantum computing is up and coming and
also there's a theory of the quantum
brain which i don't really agree with
but i do think it's a super interesting
theory and one of my professors at the
university of nijmegen is working in
this field between copper and he wrote
this paper that i think is really good
it's called an anatomic baltimore
machine capable of self-adaptation so i
think that's a good place to start and
also he gave some lectures which i will
put here so in general quantum physics
is still new how it's being used in
computing but also in neuroscience but
it's just such a fun field to dive into
and especially if you're thinking of
doing a phd in computational
neuroscience i think this is a good
field to kind of get a little bit of
flavor of what's possible in the future
okay and then the last topic is actually
neuroscience and you're probably
wondering it's computational
neuroscience why save this to the last
and that's because i think neuroscience
is one of the broadest topics that you
will have to learn about but the problem
or the difficulty with neuroscience is
because it's so broad it's kind of easy
to get lost in super specific topics
that actually in maybe the fields you
want to go to are not really applied
anymore and i also think neuroscience in
general is the easiest skill you have to
learn and that's mostly that there's not
that much
pre-requisite knowledge that you really
need to have except maybe a little bit
the anatomy of the brain but even that
you can learn during your phd pretty
fast so what you will need to learn in
neuroscience depends a lot on the field
you want to go to in the end so for
example if you want to go to genetics
and the brain so the correlation between
our genes and certain brain functions
it's good to learn a lot about genetics
but if you want to do a little bit more
what i do for example which is the link
between psychiatric disorders and
certain brain functions it's also good
to follow maybe a psychology course on
psychiatry so you can already see it's
quite hard to decide what topics to
learn in neuroscience but what i would
recommend if i started over is not to
take one course in computational
neuroscience or in neuroscience i would
actually follow the papers that are the
biggest right now in the field and read
the articles that have been published in
the last five years or so so some of the
papers that i really like are nature
reviews neuroscience and nature
neuroscience so nature in general is one
of the biggest journals in stem field
sciences and always has really good
overview papers of important findings in
the last year so some fun papers that
have been published recently are deep
learning in alternate reality and
neurons as will and representation so if
you just go to their website some of the
papers are public but for some you you
do need to pay some fee but i think
there's a discount for students or if
you're at a university usually they are
public in universities fairs and another
paper i really like is eli this is an
open journal which means that anyone can
access it that to me is really important
because some of us don't have the funds
to pay for these super expensive paper
journal subscriptions so in e-life a
friend of mine recently published and i
really like her paper so i want to brag
a little bit about this so it's charting
brain growth and aging at high spatial
precision which is really nice
and there are a few other papers that
are really nice on there and and this is
among others right there are other
journals that are really good you also
have neuron and a few others i'll list
here so i think it's just a really good
skill to
learn how to read papers get the most
important topics and then see when you
have questions or if you find a topic
really interesting to then take a little
lecture on it or a course or find a
professor that can explain a little bit
about it and another little tip that i
would do is to follow your favorite
researchers on twitter because every
time they publish something they publish
it also usually on twitter and then you
just have your automatic curated news
feed every morning of the most important
updates for you in the field so yeah
these were the resources and the skills
that i would recommend if i would start
over learning my neuroscience
computational neuroscience degree but if
you found that some skills are missing i
would love to hear them or if you have
some resources that i didn't mention
because i still have students coming and
i would always love to recommend them
the latest best resources and otherwise
see you next time bye